Es wird Zeit, euch mal wieder auf den neuesten Stand zu bringen über den europäischen Fußball der Männer. Wir wollen heute sprechen über die Lage in der Liga, in der Premier League, in La Liga, in der Eredivisie und in der Serie A mit Uli Hebel, Daniel Zander, Fabian Pakulat und Christian Bernhard jetzt hier in der Ligatur und Abfahrt. Und nun im Programm, der Rasenfunk.
Der Blick auf andere Ligen.
Ich sag's ganz ehrlich, diese Sendung, die musste reingepresst werden, wie eine Scheibe Käse in ein dicke, voll bepacktes Sandwich, aber ich habe eure Rufe erhört, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, hier ist mal wieder eine Europa Ligatur und ich freu mich sehr, dass meine Runde hier ist. Hallo in die Runde.
Moin.
Das war wie immer der Aktivitätscheck. Ah und der Internetgeschwindigkeitscheck, den hatten wir auch noch mit dabei automatisiert. Also wir sind heute über viele verschiedene Ebenen miteinander verbunden, länderübergreifend. Wir haben Stromausfälle, die hier eine Rolle hätten spielen können. Wir haben Internetprobleme, die eine Rolle spielen. Aber hoffentlich werdet ihr davon nichts merken in dieser Sendung. Wir machen es ein bisschen anders als in den vergangenen europäischen Ligaturen, weil wir jetzt schon so lange nicht mehr senden konnten. Und weil ich ehrlicherweise auch gerade noch nicht versprechen kann, wie es im Mai werden wird, machen wir einen allgemeinen Überblick über die entscheidenden Fragen in den Ligen. Und zuerst wollen wir uns mit dem Meisterrennen, dem Meisterschaftskampf in den Ligen beschäftigen und gehen da einfach mal die verschiedenen Länder durch. Und ich würde sagen, Meisterschaft, da starten wir doch mal in der Serie A, Christian, wenn du magst. Denn da hat sich ja am Wochenende was getan. Wie sieht es aktuell aus?
Also Max, dann schauen wir uns mal den Meisterschaftskampf zwischen Inter und Napoli an. Und der hat in den letzten 8, 9 Tagen eine ganz neue Wendung bekommen. Denn Inter, die ja nicht nur Titelverteidiger sind, sondern auch vorne waren, haben die letzten zwei Liga-Spieler verloren. Zwar erst gegen Bologna und jetzt am vergangenen Sonntag gegen die Roma. Und Napoli hat diese zwei Inter-Patzer genutzt und ist erst mit Inter gleichgezogen und jetzt eben am vergangenen Wochenende vorbei gezogen. Hat jetzt drei Punkte Vorsprung auf Inter. Bei vier ausstehenden Partien und damit ist klar, Napoli hat das Ding jetzt selbst in der Hand. Wenn sie aus den letzten vier Spielen zehn Punkte holen sollten, also drei Siege und Unentschieden, würde mathematisch schon reichen. Zur Erinnerung, in Italien würde es bei Punkt der Gleichheit ein Entscheidungsspiel geben, was logischerweise fantastisch wäre. Aber im Moment eben, wie gesagt, deutet jetzt einiges Richtung Napoli hin, denn Inter ist ja zu einem denkbar ungünstigen Zeitpunkt zur Saison, ja, ein bisschen die Kraft ausgegangen. Ich würde sagen, nicht nur körperlich die Kraft, sondern vor allen Dingen mental. Ich habe es jetzt in den zwei vergangenen Spielen auch kommentiert. Sie haben nicht nur gegen Bologna und gegen die Roma verloren, sondern unter der Woche, vergangene Woche auch gegen Milan, das Coppa Italia-Halbfinale-Rückspiel, also drei Niederlagen in Serie. Das gab es für Inter zuletzt 2017. Also in Sargi und Co. müssen jetzt auch irgendwie diese Negativität rausbekommen, aus den Köpfen. Das große Problem im Moment in all diesen drei Spielen, sie haben kein einziges Tor erzielt. Also der beste Angriff der Liga ist ins Stock geraten und ja, es ist jetzt eine Situation, die Inter sich logischerweise nicht so gewünscht hat, gerade jetzt vor dem Champions League-Halbfinal-Hinspiel gegen Barcelona am Mittwoch. Wie gesagt, glaube ich, geht es wirklich darum, irgendwie die mentale Müdigkeit wegzukriegen, aus den Köpfen rauszukriegen. Klar, es gibt einige Personalien, die das sicher mit reinspielen. Toram hat jetzt zum Beispiel zuletzt verletzt gefehlt. Der ist einfach sehr wichtig für diese Mannschaft. Mkhitaryan und Pastoni waren jetzt zum Beispiel gegen die Roma gesperrt. Also es haben immer wieder auch Schlüsselspieler gefehlt. Und das zeigt halt eben auch, dass Inter im Prinzip alle seine wichtigen Mann an Bord haben muss, um die großen Ziele, die sie immer noch erreichen können, auch zu erreichen. Dementsprechend ist das Pendlem jetzt Richtung Napoli ausgeschlagen. Napoli haben die in den letzten Spielen zu Null gewonnen, aber eben auch durch eine gute Offensive– und da müssen wir jetzt ganz klar Scott Mcdomine herausheben, denn der Mittelfeldspieler hat in den letzten drei Liga-Spielen fünf Tore erzielt. Napoli hat diese Spiele im Prinzip allein entschieden und wird jetzt so auf das Ziel geraten, Richtung Meisterschaft, zu dem Schlüsselspieler für Antonio Conte. Und dementsprechend, wie gesagt, Napoli hat es jetzt selbst in der Hand. Das Restprogramm spricht auch für Napoli. Also die letzten vier Gegner sind– erst geht es gegen Lecce, das ist noch mitten im Abstiegskampf, aber die letzten drei Gegner, Calderi, Parma und Genoa, für die geht es dann wahrscheinlich gar nicht mehr um so viel. Die sind eigentlich aus dem Gröbsten jetzt schon fast raus. Inter hatte es nominell auch noch schwierige Programme. Also es deutet jetzt einiges auf Napoli darauf hin. Jetzt bin ich eben gespannt, wie Napoli mit dieser veränderten, sage ich mal, Drucksituation umgeht. Denn bis vor einer Woche hat Conte und Napoli immer wieder darauf gesagt, ja, Inter ist der Favorit, wir schauen dran zu bleiben. Also hat immer schön die Favoritenrolle Richtung Inter geschoben. Jetzt hat sich das logisch gedreht. Sie sind jetzt gejagt, sie sind vorne und sie müssen schauen, dass sie jetzt mit diesem Druck auch umgehen können. Jetzt kann man sagen, ja, viele aus der Napolimannschaft, die sind ja schon vor zwei Jahren Meister geworden. Das stimmt, also die Lobotkas, die Angisars, die Lorenzas, die Politanus, Marets, also wirklich viele sind Meister geworden. Aber vor zwei Jahren war das eigentlich ein Soloritt zur Meisterschaft und da war eigentlich Nerpel schon ab Ende Januar eigentlich gar nicht mehr groß unter Druck, weil sie so einen großen Vorsprung hatten. Also sie sind nie, sei ich mal, in so eine Anspannungsdrucksituation gekommen. Und die haben sie jetzt, denn Inter, wie gesagt, ist jetzt nicht aus der Welt, sondern ist drei Punkte dahinter. Und deswegen bin ich sehr gespannt, ob sie jetzt mit dieser veränderten mentalen Situation gut umgehen und das Ganze bis zur Meisterschaft bringen. Und zu Inter noch ein Satz. Wie gesagt, hätte ich nicht gedacht bis vor Kurzem, dass sie jetzt diese drei Niederlagen innerhalb einer Woche haben, die jetzt wirklich eine ganz neue Negativität sozusagen, sie umwehen lassen, sozusagen. Aber eben gerade mit Blick auf das Champions-League-Spiel in Barcelona, ich glaube, das ist gar nicht so verkehrt für Inter. Weil jetzt, glaube ich, hat Inter kaum noch jemand auf dem Zettel. Jetzt werden sehr viele beobachtet, da kriegt man auch schon mit, ah ja gut, Barca ist eh zu stark, die Barca-Offensive. Wie soll Inter das handeln? Ich glaube, dass Inter dadurch, dass sie vor zwei Jahren schon in Champions League-Finale waren und so knapp dran war gegen City, dass diese Mission, auf die sie sich gemacht haben, schon dafür sorgen wird, dass die jetzt gerade in diesen zwei Barca-Spielen schon noch mal die mentalen Körner finden werden, weil es einfach der ganz, ganz große Traum ist. Und vielleicht ist es dann gar nicht so verkehrt, da in einer noch größeren Außenseiterrolle reinzugehen. Inter hat bewiesen, dass sie eben diese Champions-League-Spiele, gerade diese K.O.-Duelle, sehr gut bestreiten können. Und ich würde sagen, auf dem Papier, also in der Theorie, hat Inter auch zwei Tools, die, wenn sie sie richtig einzusetzen wissen, Barca wehtun können. Nämlich, erstens sind sie defensiv leidensfähig. Das wird es gegen Barca, gegen Jamal und Raffini und Co. brauchen. Das hat Inter schon oft gezeigt. Und zweitens ist ja Barca bekanntlich eine Mannschaft, die dir jeden, auf jeden Fall Räume geben wird, allein mit dieser sehr hohen Viererkette. Und ich würde sagen, es gibt wenige Mannschaften in Europa, die es schaffen, Räume so gut zu bespielen. Nicht nur über klassische Konter, sondern wirklich auch über gute Abläufe, wie wir es ja auch in den zwei Spielen gegen die Bayern gesehen haben. Und deswegen wird die Frage jetzt sein, ob Inter eben diese Energie jetzt findet Richtung Mittwoch, also Richtung Hinspiel und dann logischerweise auch Richtung Rückspiel. Aber ich würde Inter in Sachen Champions League keineswegs abschreiben, auch wenn sie jetzt diese drei Niederlagen zuletzt kassieren mussten.
Ja, was soll Barca schon gegen dieses Inter passieren? Das fragt sich natürlich auch Barca. Und damit sind wir ja auch schon in der nächsten Liga gelandet. Wir schauen mal nach Spanien. Wenn ich da auf die Tabelle blicke, Fabian, dann sehe ich, dass Barca in einer absoluten Top-Ausgangslage ist. Vor Real hat man vier Punkte Vorsprung. Und vor allem, man hat ja auch gerade dieses Copa del Rey-Finale gehabt, das sehr, sehr, sehr viel Aufregung verursacht hat. Bei Real hat man durchaus den Eindruck, da liegt ein bisschen– etwas in Trümmern ist zu viel, aber Barca ist gerade in der Top-Position. Für wie wahrscheinlich hältst du es denn, dass man aus dieser Situation heraus noch Dinge wie ein mögliches Triple und so weiter verspielt?
Na ja gut, Champions League ist auf jeden Fall noch mal nicht nur ein eigener Wettbewerb, sondern da ist mit Inter und Mailand natürlich schon eine Mannschaft da jetzt, gegen die man spielen muss, die wahrscheinlich noch mal ein Stück weit besser verteidigt als Real Madrid. Und vielleicht auch in dem Konterspiel noch ein bisschen gefährlicher ist. Also bei der Champions League bin ich mir noch nicht so sicher, vor allen Dingen gibt es ja dann auch noch ein Finale und so weiter. Aber ich gebe dir Recht, was die Liga anbelangt. Und die Copa del Rey haben wir ja gesehen am Wochenende. Ich denke aber auch, bei der Liga lassen sich die Butter nicht mehr vom Brot nehmen. Dafür ist tatsächlich, wie du schon so ein bisschen angemerkt hast, vielleicht bei Real Madrid jetzt so eine kleine Ära zu Ende. Die Anxolotti-Ära geht zu Ende. Man merkt im Kader auch an, dass da fehlt einfach dieses Jahr ein bisschen was. Dementsprechend glaube ich nicht, dass sich da an der Tabelle noch viel ändern wird. Es gibt natürlich noch den Klassikoo am 11. Mai, wo beide Mannschaften gegeneinander spielen, also in zwei Wochen. Falls da Real was reißen könnte, okay, dann wären sie wieder auf einem Punkt dran. Aber ich sehe das auch eher Barca ganz groß im Vorteil. Ich weiß noch, wie wir im Winter gesprochen haben, Christian, dass wir gesagt haben als Real, diese kleine Novemberschwäche, die da von Barca mal genutzt hat und vorbeigezogen ist, dass wir gesagt haben, Real lässt sich die Butter jetzt auch nicht mehr vom Brot nehmen. Die spielen das jetzt souverän runter, wie man es eigentlich gewohnt ist aus den letzten Jahren. Und wir haben aber gesehen, Real ist nicht das Real der letzten Jahre. Und dementsprechend halte ich Barca schon für einen Ticken stärker, die jetzt natürlich noch mit der Euphorie dieses Copa del Rey-Siegs da noch mal einen richtigen Push bekommen. Und genau, dementsprechend denke ich schon, dass die Katalaner im Moment das Heft des Handels in der Hand haben und wahrscheinlich auch die Liga sich holen werden. Champions League müssen wir mal abwarten.
Hilft das denn Barca deiner Meinung nach, dass es so viele drumherum Themen jetzt gab rund um dieses Copa del Rey-Finale? Weil rein sportlich gesehen könnte man ja schon drüber sprechen, warum die Dominanz der Anfangsphase dann irgendwann dahin war und man dann sogar in den Rückstand geraten ist und Last-Minute ausgleichen musste.
Ich denke schon, dass Real Madrid sich da im Moment keinen Gefallen tut mit der ewigen Schiedsrichter-Diskussion, mit dem ständigen Beschweren des Spielplans, auch wenn Flick sich im Nachhinein jetzt auch mal beschwert hat. In La Liga läuft alles ein bisschen anders als in Spanien. Auf jeden Fall hat sich Real Madrid schon vor dem Pokalfinale eine ungünstige Ausgangslage medial gebracht. Da waren viele Fans auch erzürnt, wie sie sich gegenüber den Schiedsrichtern verhalten haben, beziehungsweise wie der Präsident sich auch geäußert hat, wie man die Pressekonferenz am Schluss abgesagt hat, wie man einfach so beleidigte Leberwurst mäßig aufgetreten ist.
Es gab danach auch gar keine Pressekonferenz, das habe ich gar nicht mitgekriegt.
Vor dem Spiel haben sie ja die Pressekonferenz abgesagt. Nach dem Spiel gab es natürlich schon eine, aber genau. Vor dem Spiel wollten sie sich nicht mehr äußern und haben aber dann auch nicht durchgesetzt, dass der Schiedsrichter gewechselt wird. Vielleicht nochmal kurze Rewind. Am Freitag gab es die PK der Schiedsrichter und da hat eben der Schiedsrichter auch, der für das Copa del Rey-Finale angesetzt worden ist, sich beschwert über den massiven Druck, der auf den Schiedsrichtern in Spanien allgemein herrscht und vor allen Dingen von Real Madrid immer wieder ausgeübt wird. Die haben ja auch einen eigenen TV-Kanal und da wird immer wieder schön draufgeklopft. Allgemein muss man vielleicht sagen, dass in Spanien die Schiedsrichter jetzt nicht oder der Großteil nicht auf Weltklasse-Niveau ist, würde ich sagen. Also sieht man wahrscheinlich auch bei den internationalen Turnieren, dass die Spanier nicht so groß vertreten sind und weniger Finals pfeifen als vielleicht andere. Ja, aber es stimmt schon auch, dass sie einen heftigen Druck hier haben. Also, wie gesagt, nicht nur von den Clubs an sich, sondern auch von den Fans und vom ganzen Umfeld. Und ja, es ist nicht ganz einfach, hier zu pfeifen. Das stimmt schon. Aber trotzdem, Real Madrid tut sich kein Gefallen. Wenn Sport nicht richtig läuft, dann suchen sie halt den Schauplatz oder den Grund auf einer anderen Ebene. Und im Endeffekt liegt die Wahrheit auf dem Platz, wenn ich noch eine Phrase mal dreschen darf. Und da stimmt es im Moment eben nicht ganz hundertprozentig. Sie kämpfen sich dann zurück wie gegen Barca. Einfach mit einem unglaublichen Kraftakt. Aber spielerische Leichtigkeit ist nicht da.
Also dann lasst man doch ein bisschen bei Real bleiben. Wie wahrscheinlich ist es denn, dass Carlo Ancelotti noch Trainer ist über diese Saison hinaus? In Prozentpunkten vielleicht?
Gerade jetzt habe ich wieder mehrere Nachrichten gelesen, oder heute Morgen, dass der Deal mit Brasilien wohl fix sein soll und dass im Juni wohl die Ära Ancelotti zu Ende gehen wird. Das verdichten sich, also immer mehr die Anzeichen. Und ich gehe auch wirklich fest davon aus, auch weil es im Moment eben, ja, sage ich mal sportlich unschön so ein bisschen zu Ende geht, seine Ära, was er eigentlich nicht verdient hat. Aber ja, es steht einfach viele Zeichen auf Abschied. Und deshalb bleibt die Prozentsahl, die, glaube ich, liegt eher im unteren Drittel.
Und wenn man jetzt mal aufs Sportliche blickt, findest du es denn richtig, dass sich die Kritik so sehr auf Ancelotti konzentriert? Weil du hast ja auch schon gesagt, dass es ja auch im Kader durchaus auf dem Niveau von Real Madrid Schwachstellen gibt.
Absolut. Also Ancelotti kann da im Moment relativ wenig, glaube ich, besser machen. Sie haben im Mittelfeld eben das große Problem. Sie konnten Toni Kroos nie ersetzen. Sie haben keinen Spielmacher eigentlich. Zwischendurch war mal Dani Cevallos ein paar Wochen ganz gut. Dann hat er sich verletzt. Aber es sind natürlich überhaupt keinen Ersatz. Arda Güler ist noch nicht da. Also da haben sie ein großes Loch. Und die Verletzung von Bellingham, der nach wie vor mit seiner Schulter beißt und kämpft, man zieht es ihm an. Also er spielt nach wie vor eine wichtige Rolle im Team und ist nach wie vor an wichtigen Toren beteiligt, an Vorlagen und so weiter. Aber ihm fehlen locker 10, 20 Prozent, die er noch draufpacken könnte, wenn er einfach ohne Probleme in der Schulter spielen könnte. Wir haben Vinicius, der einfach auch sich seine Kämpfe außerhalb des Platzes sucht bzw. immer wieder polarisiert, immer wieder provoziert, nervt und sich dementsprechend auch immer eigenen Druck erzeugt. Ja, und dann hast du vorne den MVP, der zwar eigentlich ganz gut in Form ist, aber dem seine Mitspieler halt das Konstrukt im Moment einfach nicht funktioniert. Also im Moment würde ich sagen, es liegt nicht an Ancelotti, sondern es gibt viele kleine Stellschrauben im Spiel von Real Madrid, die einfach jetzt nicht zusammengreifen. Wie gesagt, auch noch Verletzungen bzw. angeschlagene Spieler, gesperrte Spieler. Wir haben mit Rechtsverteidiger Carvajal einen groben Ausfall, den Real Madrid nicht ersetzen kann. Egal, ob es Lucas Vazquez ist, er noch Federico Valverde, aber der fehlt dann wieder im Mittelfeld. Also für Real ist es eigentlich fast eine verquakste Saison, muss man in Anführungszeichen sagen. Die werden ja trotzdem zweiter und werden auch Champions League spielen. Aber einen Titel wird es dieses Jahr wahrscheinlich nicht geben, was mir für Angelo die Widerung ein bisschen leidtut, er ja ein sympathischer Trainer ist. Aber wie gesagt, diese Ära geht jetzt zu Ende und Schuld daran ist er mit Sicherheit nur zu einem kleineren Prozentteil, würde ich sagen.
Ich bin wirklich gespannt, also geht man in Spanien auch davon aus, dass Xabi Alonso kommt? Weil in deutschen Medien wird ja auch aus nachvollziehbaren Gründen das schon als mehr oder weniger fix angenommen, dass wenn es Angelotti geht, dass dann Alonso kommt.
Ja, also sie handeln auf jeden Fall mit seinem Namen. Einige Medien sind sich aber nicht sicher, ob er für den Schritt schon bereit ist. Jürgen Klopp taucht immer wieder auch auf, was ich für sehr bizarr halte. Aber who knows? War ja auch bizarr, dass er den aktuellen Posten angenommen hat. Also von daher keine Ahnung. Nee, schwierig zu sagen. Ich denke, es würde theoretisch passen. Allerdings wird ja auch bei San Sebastian jetzt ein Trainer-Posten frei. Da würde er eigentlich besser hinpassen. Wobei, das macht er wahrscheinlich erst am Ende seiner Karriere, Stavialonso. Aber andere Trainer-Namen werden im Moment da noch nicht mit Realen in Verbindung gebracht. Groß und von daher kann es schon sein.
Ja, bin ich echt gespannt. Wir hatten das ja hier mal schon vor vielen Monaten in der Sendung, dass irgendjemand in der Runde gesagt hat, ob das wirklich dann schon die gute zweite Station ist, also im richtigen Profifußball für Stavialonso. Die Frage stelle ich mir durchaus auch. Und eine letzte Frage noch zu Barca. Wie viele Trophäen es gegeben haben wird, das wissen wir erst in ein paar Wochen. Aber wir wissen auf jeden Fall schon, dass Hansi Flick sehr, sehr gut funktioniert bei Barca. Für wie wahrscheinlich hältst du es, dass wir in fünf Jahren zurückblicken und sagen, der hat auch eine kleine Ära mindestens gestartet? So wie wir es letztlich auch mit Ante Lotti haben. Also viele, viele Titel in kurzer Zeit.
Eine Ära ist immer ein großes Wort. Er hat Hansi Flick bei Bayern ein Ärchen gehabt. Er gewinnt. Hansi Flick hat am Anfang dieses unwahrscheinlich positive Auftreten. Er reist am Anfang alle mit. In der ersten Saison hat es bei Bayern wunderbar funktioniert. Dann schwächt es ein bisschen ab. Und Barca hat er unwahrscheinlich krass gut in den Griff bekommen, was ja alles andere als einfach ist. Aber er hat sich einfach die Spieler gecatcht. Er hat sie auf emotionaler Ebene geholt. Er hat sie auf sportlicher Ebene. Da haben ihm die Erfolge natürlich dann auch geholfen und so weiter. Und er lässt sie auch spielen. Aber er ist wirklich ein sehr guter Kommunikator. Alle Spieler loben ihn, wie gut er mit ihnen umgeht, auch mit den Ersatzspielern und so weiter. Und die haben sich jetzt einfach in den Rausch gespielt, dieses Sohn. Da wären sie nicht zu stoppen, seien sie in der Liga. Also ich denke mal, neben dem Copa del Rey-Titel wird er tatsächlich mindestens zwei Titel holen in seinem ersten Jahr. Das haben wir vor, dass er so auch nicht geglaubt, glaube ich. Keiner von uns. Und Champions League werden wir abwarten, aber ich halte es nicht für ausgeschlossen. Trotzdem ist es natürlich so bei Barca defensiv abwarten.
Jetzt auch erst mal das Halbfinale abwarten. Da hat er schon ein paar Dinge zu gesagt. Also das ist die Situation in Spanien. Und das ist ganz interessant. Die Parallele, die wir hier haben, ist immer wie die europäischen Pokalwettbewerbe mit der Liga konkurrieren und wie man da auch Entscheidungen treffen muss. Und Daniel in der Eredivisie, da hat Ajax Amsterdam die Entscheidung getroffen, Europa League nicht so bock drauf. Rückspiel bei Eintracht Frankfurt ist uns doch egal, dass ein paar tausend niederländische Fans rübergereist sind. Wir treten da mit der BF auf, denn für uns zählt nur die Liga. Dann gab es einen Unentschieden direkt nach diesem Ausscheiden bei Eintracht Frankfurt. Also das sah sehr schlecht aus. Wenn ich allerdings jetzt auf die Tabelle blicke, dann sehe ich Ajax 7 Punkte vor PSV. Also alles wunderbar funktioniert und alles ganz toll bei Ajax Amsterdam?
Eigentlich nicht so tatsächlich. Man mag es meinen, aber man kann uns dazu aber auch sagen, dass der Abstand von Ajax auf Eintracht Frankfurt auch schon mal größer war. Und das ist recht interessant. Also vor ungefähr einem Monat gab es ja das sehr virtuell auch gegen Eintracht Frankfurt. Ajax gewonnen, da waren es dann schon 9 Punkte Vorsprung. Und da dachte man eigentlich gut, das Ding ist gelaufen. Vor allem auch den aktuellen Fond-Korven von Ajax und Eintracht Frankfurt entsprechend. Also Ajax hatte eigentlich da einen sehr guten Flow drin in der Liga, hatte ja mit Fahri Uli, diesem sehr defensiven System, diesen defensiven Phasen eigentlich Struktur drinne, Ordnung drinne. Und Eintracht Frankfurt hatte so ein bisschen ein anderes Gesicht gezeigt als vergangenes Jahr. Die hatten grobe Schnitzer immer wieder drinne, unkonzentrierte Halten. Und es war eigentlich nicht damit zu rechnen, dass das noch mal irgendwie spannend wird. Aber spannenderweise, genau nach diesem Spiel, haben sich diese beiden Merkmale, diese beiden Eigenschaften, diese beiden Mannschaften, vertauscht. Man kann schon sagen, Ajax hatte jetzt zuletzt einen 4-0 gegen Gütrecht verloren, was mehr war als nur ein Betriebsunfall. Und jetzt zuletzt nur ein 1-1 gegen Sparta. Das sind schon mal wieder fünf Punkte, denen hat liegen lassen. Und Eindhoven hat in der Zeit alles gewonnen in der Liga, drei Spiele. Auch souverän. Also auch wieder in dieser eigentlich typisch PSV-artigen Phase, die sie haben. Und man darf nicht vergessen, es sind sieben Punkte. Aber Ajax hat ein Spiel schon mehr gespielt. Das heißt, Eindhoven, wenn die jetzt am Wochenende ihr Spiel gewinnen gegen Zitat, sind es dann nur noch vier Punkte. Und dann wird es dann vielleicht doch wieder spannend. Also ich gehe nicht davon aus, immer noch nicht, dass Ajax nicht Meister wird. Aber es ist schon so, dass jetzt auch wieder ein bisschen Druck aufkommt. Und ich glaube, was Christian auch schon gesagt hat, diese mentale Druck, ist nochmal eine andere Sache jetzt. PSV kann aufspielen, hat vermutlich auch selbst nicht bedankt geklaut, dass das nochmal irgendwie spannend werden kann, nachdem die Duellen gegen Ajax sich verloren haben. Und seitdem läuft es bei PSV aber wieder rund. Und deswegen ist die Tür für PSV schon wieder einen Spalt geöffnet. Und man darf schon gespannt sein, ob Ajax in den letzten drei Spielen, die sie haben, dann doch nochmal wieder ein bisschen souveräner auftreten. Man muss auch sagen, dass bei dem 4-0 man eigentlich alles hat fehler sehen. Also gerade was Körpersprache angeht, was Einsatz angeht. Zwei oder drei von diesen vier Toren wurden einfach auch nur zugesehen. Im Prinzip, da wurden zwei Kämpfe verloren in der Luft. Das war also wirklich untypisch für Ajax. Und bei dem 1-2-1 gegen Sparta gab es eigentlich auch eine Situation, die symptomatisch ist für das Ajax in den letzten zwei, drei Wochen. Da gab es dann einen Rückpass aus dem Lehrbuch kontrolliert zum Torwart. Und Matthias im Tor dachte sich, die nehme ich auf. Es gab dann einen direkten Freistoß. Und da resultiert das 1 zu 0 in der 90. Und Ajax hat noch sehr, sehr Dusel, dass die Posts wenn noch das 1-1 gemacht haben, um die Punktwesen zu retten. Und das sind so unkonzentrierteheiten, die man eigentlich im Laufe der Saison eher PSV zu beschrieben hat. Und das hat sich jetzt getauscht. Und ja, mal gucken, ob die Tür noch weiter aufgeht oder ob es dann doch noch ein zu großer Vorsprung war, den sich Ajax selber die Zeit erspielt hat. Das ist das, was ich glaube.
Aber wie wird denn das aufgenommen jetzt im Umfeld von Ajax? Denn wir haben ja, also Ajax ist ja das Sorgenkind. Dann war es das Überraschungsteam. Zwischendurch war es auch mal ein bisschen skandalös bei Ajax. Also man könnte hier oberflächlich betrachtet auch sagen, ist doch alles super. Also wer hätte erwartet, dass Ajax so schnell wieder an die Tabellenspitze kommen würde und dass man dann noch ein bisschen wackelt. Okay, das ist so. Aber ich könnte mir vorstellen, dass das halt auch die typische Aussage von jemandem ist, der emotional ein bisschen weiter entfernt von dem Ganzen ist und auch die tägliche Berichterstattung nicht mitbekommt.
Also sagen wir so, nicht dann betrachtet, rein nicht dann betrachtet, selbst wenn sie es noch, wenn sie es schon, wenn sie jetzt weiter werden sollten und nicht Meister werden sollten trotz des Vorsprungs, wäre es immer noch davon ausgehend zu sehen, woher sie kommen, eine fast schon herausragende Saison, weil sie ja wirklich am Tiefpunkt waren. Also das war ja in der Vereinsgeschichte von Ajax suchte so eine Saison wie die letzte dann das Gleiche. Aber es ist dann schon so, wenn du dann da oben bist und hast dann irgendwann neun Punkte Vorsprung, hast du natürlich auch im Umfeld eine andere Erwartungshaltung. Und wenn du dann sagst, naja gut, so wie sich Ajax präsentiert hat im Verlauf der Saison, dann einen neun Punkte Vorsprung dann noch am Ende vielleicht herzugeben, das darf dir ja nicht passieren, auch wenn du eigentlich in der Entwicklung noch auf einer anderen Stufe bist. Insofern kann ich dich da schon verstehen, aber mir als auch Fan natürlich mit der Fernbrille, sage auch, bei neun Punkten Vorsprung, du hast gegen die großen Brocken der Liga auch schon gespielt, auch schon gewonnen. Wenn du dann natürlich gegen Utrecht so eine Klatsche dir abholst, dann ein Punkt widerliegen, das gegen Sparta, das muss ja auch nicht sein. Und was eben auch noch eine Rolle spielt, ist das von dir angesprochene, ich will sagen zumindest vom Image, der Debakel gegen Frankfurt, denn da mit einer BF aufzutreten, wo eigentlich noch alles drin war, das Hinspiel war mit einem Tom-Street verloren. Das war jetzt nicht, dass man da irgendwie 4-0 nach Hause geschickt wurde, wo man sagt, naja, gut, das ist nirgends auslaufen. Nein, das war, also Frankfurt, klar, das ist eine schwierige Aufgabe, aber es war alles möglich für Ajax. Und es war auch nicht so, dass im Hinspiel Frankfurt Ajax irgendwie dann an die Wand gespielt hätte oder so. Und dann auch sich noch hinzustellen mit Aussagen wie, ja, ich wollte Spieler für eine eventuelle Verlängerung schonen. Das sind Aussagen, die kamen natürlich nicht gut an und stoßen auch auf viel Unverständnis. Und da hat Ferrioli auch sehr viel Kredit verspielt tatsächlich, weil es eine Entscheidung ist, die man eigentlich nicht nachvollziehen kann. Also dann gab es auch schon Gerüchte, dass es auch so ein bisschen eine indirekte Botschaft an den Sportvorstand war. Weil Ferrioli mit den Transfers auch unzufrieden ist, hat er auch schon im Laufe der Saison mehrfach gesagt. Und nach dem Motto, ja, seht her, wenn ich groß votiere, habe ich ja keinen mehr. Allerdings ist auch die Frage, ob man wirklich auf 10 Positionen votieren muss oder ob das dann nicht vielleicht etwas außergewöhnlich ist. Und insofern ist das– hat er viel verspielt. Und wenn du dann mit so einem Statement– und das ist, finde ich, schon ein Statement– in die weitere Saison gehst und dann verspielst du dann aber 9 Punkte Vorsprung, dann ist das nochmal eine andere Aushangsweise, ein anderer Aushangspunkt als vor diesem Frankfurt.
Und das halt auch noch gegen PSV, die ja wiederum auf der anderen Seite auch einen interessanten Saisonverlauf haben. Also, dass man eben quasi abgefangen wurde von Ajax, dann diese Niederlage und jetzt ist man irgendwie doch noch mit dabei. Wie ist denn da die Situation?
Ja, das ist, glaube ich, das Gegenteil von Ajax. Da, wo jetzt ein bisschen Druck herrscht, hatten die nach diesem direkten Duell, was für mich wirklich so ein Wendepunkt und Fixbrück sein kann, eigentlich keinen Druck mehr gehabt, sagt der Mutter, ja gut, man hat sich entschieden. Sie spielen freier auf und das merkt man auch. Also, sie denken weniger nach und manchmal hilft das ja. Und das sieht man eigentlich in den letzten Spielen, dass dieser PSV-Floor wiederkommt. Sie denken nicht groß nach, sondern spulen einfach ihr Potenzial ab, haben es wieder erreicht und genau das hilft ihnen jetzt. Und ich vergleiche das immer so ein bisschen mit darts, im dartsport, wenn man dann irgendwie ganz, wenn man eigentlich schon irgendwie 5, 6 Lacks hinten ist und die Pfeile eigentlich nicht in die Trippe wollen, dann geht es auf einmal, weil man weiß, okay, es ist vorbei, man wirft einfach und PSV spielt einfach. Und dass sie jetzt die Qualität haben, um zu spielen, das haben sie ja gezeigt. Aber da glaubt noch niemand ernsthaft, dass man am Ende dann doch noch auf eins steht. Aber es ist zumindest jetzt bei Ajax wieder Erddruck da, weil sie auch merken, dass PSV einfach spielt.
Ich sag mal so, also sollte PSV jetzt dann, also gegen Zitthard natürlich muss man gewinnen, aber dann auswärts bei Ferienort, das ist natürlich ein ganz eigenes Thema. Aber sollte man irgendwie dieses Spiel gewinnen mit der neuen Leichtigkeit oder warum auch immer, dann könnte ich mir vorstellen, dass es richtig, richtig interessant wird an den letzten beiden Spieltagen. Da können wir uns alle darauf freuen und wir freuen uns auch, dass wir, wenn wir auf die Premier League blicken, nicht mehr sagen müssen, vielleicht wird X, Y Meister, sondern jetzt können wir Lob rudeln, Uli, der FC Liverpool. Er hat es geschafft, er ist zum 20. Mal Englischer Meister geworden und eben zum ersten Mal seit Ewigkeiten, seit Dekaden vor eigenem Publikum, weil die Corona-Meisterschaft unter Jürgen Klopp irgendwie so ein bisschen außer der Reihe lief. Was waren das für Momente am Wochenende? Wie nimmst du das wahr? Du kennst ja auch die Art und Weise, wie auch solche Meisterschaften zelebriert werden. Ich habe jetzt ehrlicherweise schon länger keine Meisterfeier mehr verfolgt, aber ich war völlig hin und weg, ehrlicherweise, von dem Stil, von der Gemeinschaft zwischen Fans und Teams und auch von der Art und Weise, wie Arne Slott diesen Titel gefeiert hat. Wie ging es dir?
Es ist genauso ähnlich. Ich habe mein Gesicht gleich mal angepasst, farblich, um Liverpool zu feiern. Ich habe es nicht so mit der Sonnencreme gehabt gestern. Genauso wie du. Ich habe mich so ertappt bei dem Gedanken, als ich die da habe singen sehen. Das ist ja mehrfach I'll never walk alone angestimmt worden. Ich habe mich so ertappt, dass ich mir gedacht habe, ist das alles wahr, was diese Spieler da machen, die singen, die das wirklich aus Inbrunst. Wenn du dann aber in die Gesichter blickst, insbesondere bei Van Dyke, glaube ich, oder Robertson, oder die wirklich aus dem eigenen Nachwuchs kommen. Bei Bradley ist es mir extrem aufgefallen, bei Curtis Jones, dass ich wirklich dachte, Mensch, das gibt es echt noch. Es ist nicht nur Geld und es ist nicht nur, nur in Anfangsrängen, es ist natürlich wahnsinnig viel, aber es sind nicht nur Titel, sondern es geht schon auch darum, das dann mit denen zu feiern, weil die, glaube ich, schon verstehen bei Liverpool, dass dieses Umfeld, dieses Stadion schon noch mal einzigartig ist. Also das Band, das es gibt zwischen Publikum oder– machen wir es weiter– Umfeld und Mannschaft, was ja dann letztlich auch dazu geführt hat, dass zwei der drei großen auslaufenden Verträge letztlich verlängert werden konnten. Der eine wahrscheinlich nicht, wenn man jetzt auch John W. Henry nochmal gehört hat, aber dann habe ich schon auch das Gefühl, dass es auf der einen Seite jetzt nicht mehr…
Entschuldigung, Alexander Arnaud nicht.
Alexander Arnaud, ja, genau, genau.
Und Salah und Daik eben schon.
Genau, die sind ja schon unter Dach und Fach. Ja, sorry, war zu schnell. Und ich muss auch sagen, was mir gefällt an der ganzen Sache ist, dass– klar, das war jetzt nicht mehr total sensationell, weil sich alle darauf eingestellt haben, dass es diese Meisterschaftsfeier geben wird, aber ich war auch mal vor zwei Jahren, glaube ich, auf drei Jahren bei einer Bayern-Meisterschaft anwesend, wo es ebenfalls so war am 33. Spieltag. Und da hatte ich das Gefühl, so na gut, nach zehn Minuten kann man das Ding jetzt auch zumachen, weil es interessiert hier eh niemanden mehr. Und trotz dessen, glaube ich, haben alle auch nochmal begriffen– das muss man sich ja nochmal vor Augen führen– Jahr eins nach Jürgen Klopp. Die haben letztes Jahr um die Zeit auch gefeiert, aber anders und ohne was in den Händen dargestanden zu sein. Und diese Premier League zu gewinnen, Jahr eins nach Klopp, im Jahr zwei nach einem totalen Umbau, das, glaube ich, haben die auch alle verstanden. Das ist trotzdem groß. Also auch wenn es jetzt am Ende so aussah, als würden sie so mehr oder weniger ins Ziel gehumpelt, was ich ihnen nicht übel nehme, weil einfach kein Druck mehr drauf war auf der ganzen Sache. Und sie ja auch nur noch in dem einen Wettbewerb, dann spielen letztlich. Aber wie du sagst, auch mit einer gewissen Klasse, mit einer wohltuenden Zurückhaltung, also nicht irgendwie so, gibt es ja dann auch, dass Spieler in Kameras laufen und so, ich, ich, ich. Und nicht anders, sondern das war wirklich, hatte eine gewisse Klasse, das Ganze. Und so, wie Arnes Lotz sich vorgestellt hat, so hat er dann auch nochmal, das finde ich immer ganz, ganz groß, wenn es in Momenten, in denen es eigentlich um ihn geht, und das ist ganz klar sein Erfolg, trotzdem nochmal, er macht es zu einem Erfolg auch der anderen. Und das mag ich immer super gerne. Und das ist genauso, wie ich Arnes Lotz auch kennengelernt habe.
Also er hat unter anderem den Fangesang, den Jürgen Klopp für ihn angestimmt hat bei dessen Abschied, den hat er quasi zurückgegeben und zwar als Allererstes. Nach dem Glückwunsch, also eben, das war eben auch hoch priorisiert und haben ja wahrscheinlich auch viele Hörerinnen und Hörer mitbekommen. Jetzt habe ich mich gefragt rund um dieses Spiel, das ja sehr eindeutig war, also klar Rückstand, aber dann haben sie Tottenham hergespielt und Tottenham ist ja sowieso eine ganz eigene Traurige-Geschichte für sich. Wahnsinn! Wir werden sie im Abstiegssegment nicht mehr thematisieren, aber Rang 16 ist es aktuell für die Teams. Also das ist echt... Na ja, holen halt die Europa League, wie es dann so funktioniert bei solchen Teams. Nein, aber... Worüber ich dann noch mal nachgedacht habe war, wir haben ja immer mal wieder über Liverpool gesprochen, wir haben auch darüber gesprochen, was Arne Slot verändert hat, und wir haben aber vor allem immer oft über die großen Namen gesprochen. Also Mo Salah, nicht nur wegen der Vertragsverlängerung. Wer würdest du denn sagen, sind denn so die etwas untergegangenen Helden dieses Titels?
Also im Grunde genommen ist es trotzdem schon Mo Salah, das ist schon eine Saison für die Geschichtsbücher, und ich glaube, da wird er sich auch noch drin verebigen, auch zahlenmäßig, dass diese Saison für immer steht. Wenn ich jetzt aber so meinen klassischen Unsung-Hero um die alte Kategorie nochmal wieder zu zelebrieren nehme, dann würde ich sagen, wobei der ist auch viel besungen worden, Ryan Gravenberg ist schon fast kriminell konstant gewesen auf einer Position, die ich ihm nicht zugetraut hätte vor der Saison. Das war eigentlich immer so, wenn du dich erinnerst, an unser allererstes Segment Vorschau, habe ich auch gesagt, die sind den einen Sechser davon entfernt, dass sie eingreifen können.
Genau.
Und dann kommt einfach mal Ryan Gravenberg und hat einfach nie ein schlechtes Spiel gemacht. Selbst in der Phase, als es mal so aussah, als könnte er minimal einbrechen, war es immer noch auf absolutem Top-Top-Niveau. Natürlich auch nicht verletzt, das ist auch so ein Grund. Ich glaube, ich habe vorhin Every Bradley gesagt, Connor Bradley natürlich. Every war ein Basketballspieler. Da ist er noch hoffentlich. Connor Bradley, der in dem Moment gekommen ist, als als verletzungsbedingt jemand gefehlt hat. Robertson hat mir in der Saison nicht so gut gefallen. Da hat Simikas gut genug gemacht, dass das nicht aufgefallen ist. Soboslay hatte zwar ein paar Tiefen, aber auch brutale Höhen, eher zu Beginn der Saison, wohlgemerkt. Der hat leicht nachgelassen und Curtis Jones hat für mich den Schritt gemacht, den ich noch mal sehen wollte, so ganz final, den zu machen, dass er wirklich ein Top-Spieler sein kann. Bei McAllister ist es jetzt, also hat ein Weilchen gebraucht, der Anlauf letzte Saison, ein halbes Jahr, muss man ihm auch gönnen. Dann war es eh schon ziemlich gut in der Saison. Aber es ist der Wahnsinn, der zählt für mich unter die absolut besten Mittelfeldspieler überhaupt, sodass man vielleicht den Mannschaftsteil Mittelfeld nochmal ganz besonders hervorheben muss, wo es halt vier Leute gab, die auf einem wahnsinnig hohen Niveau gespielt haben, die ganze Saison über.
Das ist schon irre mit Rheingravenberg. Thomas Hitzelsberger hat es ja in der Übertragung bei Sky auch gesagt, auf eine ähnliche Frage als Antwort, dass das für ihn ebenso der Stelle hält ist. Ich wundere mich, dass das nicht so sehr in deutschen Medien seinen Widerhall findet, weil es ja doch wirklich, zumindest bemerkenswert ist, dass jemand, der bei Bayern sehr schnell aussortiert wird, eine solche Rolle spielt bei einem der besten Teams Europas.
Ich finde auch, im Nachhinein natürlich ist man eh immer klüger. Ich habe damals ein bisschen mit den Verantwortlichen geredet. Das war jetzt nicht nur eine sportliche Überlegung von Bayern, ihn gehen zu lassen, sondern er war wohl schon auch sehr ungeduldig. Woraufhin er dann ja auch öfter mal einen Kaderplatz verloren hat. Da gab es ja mal unter Nagelsmann damals noch die eine Pressekonferenz, wo er, glaube ich, gesagt hat, er spielt auf jeden Fall. Und dann war er aber nicht im Kader oder hat zumindest gar nicht gespielt. Und das hatte halt damit zu tun, dass er in den Niederlanden ein Interview gegeben hat, wo er dann einmal rund umgeschlagen hat gegen die Bayern, wo ich dann auch verstehen kann, dass man so einem Jungen sagt, pass auf, du kannst es auch nicht… Also es geht halt nicht, dass du in den Mittelkreis machst und dann noch die Stöckchen reinsteckst. Das geht halt auch nicht. Und trotzdem ist es natürlich im Nachhinein eigentlich ein brutaler Fehler, wenn man den jetzt so sieht. Weil das war ja immer klar, dass wenn der halbwegs an sein Potenzial geht mit dem Körper, mit der Geschmeidigkeit, die er trotz Körpergröße auch hat, mit der Ballkontrolle und wenn man… Also das habe ich auch immer noch im Hinterkopf. Ten Haag hat ihn immer auf seiner Arbeitsmoral gelobt. Hat aber immer auch dazu gesagt, man muss halt wissen bei ihm, dass man ihn entsprechend anfasst. Also man braucht halt ein Grundvertrauen und dann macht er für dich alles, was du willst. Ich weiß nicht, ob man den damals bei Bayern verpflichtet hat und sich dessen nicht bewusst war oder ob man einfach grundsätzlich die Schnauze voll hat, der wird natürlich im Nachhinein bitter, weil der Spieler, der ist halt heute 120 Millionen wert, wenn du den ablösen möchtest. Gab jetzt vor ein, zwei Wochen die Gerüchte um Real Madrid. Da sieht man auch mal wieder, welcher Typ er ist. Da hat er jetzt nicht gesagt, nee, jetzt alles cool. Ich habe jetzt mal meine erste Saison Stammspieler bei Liverpool. Ich würde gerne noch die Champions League. Da war schon zwischen den Zeilen zu lesen, ich würde es machen. Das ist natürlich auch nicht so ganz clever. Und das ist der Typ, der er ist. Ich glaube auch, dass das so dieses neu gewonnene Selbstbewusstsein manchmal von Fußballern ist, die sich dann selber so in die Pflicht nehmen. Ich mag das ganz gerne. Ich habe da was dafür übrig. Und nach der Saison darf er im Grunde sagen, was er will, weil die war einfach super.
Das ist so. Und wer nicht bei YouTube gerade mit dabei ist, Daniel als alter Ajax-Afficionado, der gönnt das Reib im Grabenberg ganz offensichtlich auch nach aller Reaktion, die ich gerade so gesehen habe. Schönen Weg, den Grabenberg gegangen ist. Und der ist ja noch lange nicht zu Ende. Wenn wir mal auf die Liga noch mal zuletzt blicken, Uli, das ist natürlich eigentlich nicht das Idealszenario. Du willst als Liga die Meisterschaft am letzten Spieltag haben. Und gerade in der Premier League hatte man sich eine Zeit lang schon daran gewöhnt. Dann kam Manchester City, ehrlicherweise, und hat das Ganze gedreht. Ist das irgendwie auch ein Thema, dass dieser Titel von Liverpool, der natürlich absolut verdient ist bei zwei Niederlagen in 34 Spielen, aber 15 Punkte Abstand, zeigt ja auch, es gibt auch eine begleitende Schwäche der anderen.
Die gab es in der Saison. Das ist ja das Untypische. Also man kann jetzt auf der einen Seite sagen, City hatte das Ganze langweilig gemacht, aber die wurden ja gepusht von den anderen Teams. Also letztes Jahr Arsenal im Jahr davor oder in den Jahren davor Liverpool, das darf man ja auch nicht vergessen. Ich glaube, dass ist eine Teilwahrheit über die Meisterschaft Liverpools, die jetzt so in den letzten Wochen so vor sich hin sichtete, dass einfach der Druck von hinten nicht mehr da war. Das kann man jetzt auf der einen Seite nehmen als Schwäche der anderen. In der Saison ist es ja ziemlich klar die Schwäche von Manchester City, die sich leicht stabilisieren. Ja, aber Arsenal als Beispiel, die haben, glaube ich, einfach mit sich selbst zu kämpfen gehabt. Ich bin immer noch nicht so ganz schlüssig darüber, war es jetzt selbstverschulden, war es Fremdeinwirkung aufgrund von Verletzungen. Wahrscheinlich ist die Wahrheit irgendwo zwischendrin. Und zuletzt gibt es eine relativ klare Priorisierung sinnhafter Weise Richtung Champions League. Aber das Problem ist, wenn man so argumentiert, dann macht man automatisch so ein Sternchen an die Meisterschaft Liverpools. Und das gehört da nicht hin. Weil die waren von Tag 1 an wahnsinnig gut, superschwierig zu schlagen, wie du es gesagt hast. Und haben eigentlich ganz lang nur gegen Nottingham mal verloren in dem Spiel. Das habe ich damals kommentiert. Das hätten sie halt auf jeden Fall 3-0 gewinnen müssen, so wie Nottingham eigentlich in jedem Spiel 3-0 verlieren muss. Ist aber halt nicht passiert. Und okay, ist dann halt mal ein Unfall. Und ich behaupte immer noch, weiß aber nicht, ob es so ist, die haben eine Niederlage im Pflichtspielen gehabt, die zu viel war gegen Paris Saint-Germain. Okay, das wissen wir alle. Die war auch einigermaßen krachend, würde ich sagen, so wie sie passiert ist. Okay, aber halt auch nur die eine. Und wenn die weiter in dem Champions-League-Wettbewerb dabei bleiben oder auch noch im FA Cup, dann glaube ich, würde dieser Mini-Einbruch gar nicht mehr passieren. Und dann marschieren die da durch. Weil die haben ja zu Beginn der Saison, war es nicht immer unterhaltsam in dem Sinne, aber ganz viel von dem, was ich immer gefordert habe, und deswegen möchte ich das als absoluten Pluspunkt herausstellen, Game-Management. Das gab es ja nicht in der letzten Saison unter Club. Da war es rauf und runter und immer 4-3, manchmal auch dann 3-3 hinten raus. In der Saison waren es ganz häufig einfach ein 1-0 oder ein 2-1 oder ein 2-0. Da ist dann einfach nichts mehr passiert in der letzten halben Stunde. Und das ist etwas, was du in der Premier League aber absolut, absolut überlebenswichtig brauchst, wenn du irgendwas reißen willst. Und das haben sie gemacht. Und deswegen will ich gar nicht so sehr sagen, klar haben sich die anderen Punkte weggenommen, aber die werden auch in einer anderen Saisonmeister geworden. Da bin ich mir eigentlich ziemlich sicher.
Unbedingt. Und jetzt sind wir sowieso schon quasi ins zweite Segment reingerückt, nämlich uns rennen um die europäischen Plätze, also Champions League, Europa League, Conference League. Spielt ihr auch noch mit rein, dass die Premier League sehr wahrscheinlich noch einen weiteren Champions League-Starter bekommen wird? Kannst du uns da noch einen kurzen Überblick geben? Wie steht es da?
Ja, also Arsenal sieht gut aus auf der 2. Und dann gibt es noch einen Rennen von 3 bis 7. City ist im Moment stabil, sieht so aus zumindest. Sind jetzt auch im FA Cup-Finale am Wochenende gewonnen. Spielen dagegen Oliver Glasners Crystal Palace, was auch schon wieder eine Wahnsinnsgeschichte für sich ist, dass Glasner halt original wieder ins Pokalfinale geht.
Wie ist es, das dritte Pokalfinale innerhalb von vier Jahren für ihn als Trainer?
Genau, er sagt ja selber drei in Folge, weil letztes Jahr konnte er ja nichts mehr.
Ach ja, stimmt.
Es war ja für ihn unmöglich, dann noch was zu tun. Da kann er nichts dafür. Also es ist schon echt krass. Und by the way, wenn ich ihm einen Rat geben würde, dann tritt zurück nach der Saison, weil ganz England hat jetzt gesehen, du hast es drauf. Und da kommt ein größerer Verein. Und Crystal Palace wird es eh nie lernen. Daher, glaube ich, würde ich an seiner Stelle sagen, danke, das war es jetzt hier. Anders als in Frankfurt damals, aber so würde ich es machen, wenn ich er wäre. Genau, dann gibt es so eine Verfolgertruppe, die unterschiedlich stabil sind. Newcastle dachte ich eigentlich eine Zeit lang, okay, die sind voll dabei. Die sahen sehr, sehr gut aus. Haben relativ wenig Verletzungsprobleme, insbesondere verglichen mit der letzten Saison. Haben aber gegen Aston Villa richtige Ohrfeige bekommen vor zwei Wochen mit einem 4-1, als man auch gesehen hat, oh, es gibt doch noch die Spuren von, manchmal tauchen sie einfach nicht auf. Dann gibt es Chelsea, die auch sich ergebnistechnisch wieder leicht stabilisiert haben, die aber bei weitem nicht mehr die Leichtigkeit haben des Teams, dass sie waren bis Weihnachten. Kein Cole Palmer mehr, also nicht mal mehr in der Nähe der Form, die er hatte. Nicholas Jackson kommt langsam zurück, aber die haben ihre Schwierigkeiten mitunter und machen immer noch dafür zu viele individuelle Fehler. Das ist ein junges Team, das Jüngste mit Abstand, das Jüngste. Dann gibt es Aston Villa, die wieder aufgewacht sind. Nach dieser ganzen Mehrfachbelastung, die hat ihnen offensichtlich zugesetzt. Sie haben auch ein gutes Winterfenster hingelegt. Die kommen von hinten nochmal, die schieben auch ganz schön an. Denen würde ich es noch mal zutrauen, dass sie wirklich bis zum Ende mit dabei bleiben. Und Nothing in Forest ist halt noch da, die weiterhin sich die Ergebnisse ergrinden. Aber es ist jetzt nicht… Also City habe ich inzwischen wieder relativ sicher auf der 3, auch wenn das fast nur noch ein Umschalteam jetzt ist inzwischen. Aber die sind so weit gestabilisiert, glaube ich. Also nicht stabil für ihre Verhältnisse, aber so weit. Und dann geht es halt um die zwei Plätze noch unter den genannten Mannschaften.
Uli, vielen lieben Dank für diese Zusammenfassung. Du musst weiter. Ganz, ganz herzlichen Dank. Du kannst dich einfach auslocken und lass den Tab noch kurz offen. Stimmt, das habe ich vergessen zu sagen, dass alles hochgeladen wird. Bis bald, Uli. Uli ist weg und Christian ist uns leider auch abhandengekommen. Deswegen blicken wir jetzt erstmal nicht auf die Serie A. Und ich kann euch aktuell auch gerade nicht versprechen, ob wir das noch schaffen in dieser Sendung. Ihr könnt es euch nicht vorstellen, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, welche technischen Probleme wir ausgerechnet bei dieser Aufzeichnung hier haben. Stellt euch das Schlimmstmögliche vor und multipliziert es mit zwei. Also wir sitzen quasi gleichzeitig in Mecklenburg-Vorpommern und in Brandenburg. Das wäre so ungefähr die Referenz, die ich jetzt mal hier für die deutschen ZuhörerInnen bilden würde. Daniel, dann machen wir mit dir weiter in der Hoffnung, dass das jetzt auch hier funktioniert. Dann lass uns auf die Eredivise blicken und eben das Rennen um Europa. Was ist da wichtig zu wissen?
Es gibt quasi zwei Spotlights, die ich richten würde. Das erste Spotlight ist der Kampf um die Champions League. Ich muss dazu sagen, die ersten Mal in der Eredivise gehen fix in die CL. Ajax werden von hinten gesagt eventuell doch nicht Meister, auch wenn es gut aussieht, aber in der CL sind sie eigentlich ziemlich sicher dabei. Sie haben 12 Punkte Vorsprung auf Platz 3, bei noch 12 Punkten zu holen. Das sollte ein Selbstlöffel sein. Hol dir mal irgendwo einen Punkt, oder gewinn Feyenoord einmal nicht, ist Ajax sicher in der Champions League. Spannend wird es um Platz 2 bis 4, denn Eindhoven tut gut daran, auch das Diakotuell gegen Feyenoord, das Tor von David das zu gewinnen. Aktuell sind es 5 Punkte Vorsprung vor Platz 3. Platz 3 würde zur CL-Quali berechtigen. Wenn das Diakotuell verloren geht gegen Feyenoord, sind es noch 2 Punkte Vorsprung bei noch 2 aufstehenden Spieltagen. Das könnte nochmal Ludwig Feuer geben. Man muss dazu sagen, dass Platz 3 für beide Vereine aber auch noch okay wäre, wenn man davon ausgeht, dass man die Quali übersteht. Ich bin ja noch Champions League. Spannend wird es auch vor allem auf Platz 4. Da steht Utrecht, die hatten wir auch schon mal im Rasenfunk beleuchtet. Die haben sich jetzt auch sicher mindestens für die EL-Quali qualifiziert. Die können nicht mehr auf Platz 500 tiefer fallen. Um mal der alten Kategorie zu fröhnen, gibt es auch einen Men-of-the-Match-Most-Value-Player. Dabei kannte er Sebastian Haller. Der hat einen guten Start gehabt. Da kam viel Leerlauf. Der hatte nicht die richtige Bindung zum Spiel. Aber der hat jetzt in den letzten drei Spielen jeweils ein Tor erzielt und hat auch jetzt wieder eine Bindung zum Spiel gefunden. Und ist auch mit dem Faktor, dass Utrecht nach einem kleinen Durchhänger vor ein paar Wochen wieder die Spur gefunden hat und mindestens vörter wird. Diesen Punkt gleich mit Feyenoord haben ein Spiel mehr schon gespielt. Also die leichteren Voraussetzungen. Aber auch Utrecht schaut natürlich noch auf Platz 3. Und für Feyenoord wäre es der absolute Worst-Case, wenn sie Platz 3 verspielten und Platz 4 hatten würden, denn sie brauchen die Einnahmen. Sie haben einen sehr teuren Kader. Nach der Meisterschaft vergangenes Jahr haben sie viel investiert. Vor zwei Jahren haben sie viel investiert und viele die Gehaltstruktur schon nach oben geschraubt. Was ist jetzt recht, wenn du dann mal nur vörter werden solltest. Das heißt, bei Veynord geht es auch noch um sehr viel. Und auch um den Stand von Neutriner van Persie, der sich auch beweisen muss und eigentlich die ZD-Equally holen muss. Das ist so das eine Thema. Das andere Thema ist ja noch sehr, sehr offen. Das ist der Kampf um die Europa League und vor allem um die River Conference League. Da haben wir eine sehr spannende Situation. Denn rein theoretisch hast du selbst Platz 15 Zwolle noch rechtere Chancen auf die Conference League. Und das verdanken wir einem sehr spannenden System, was man auch gut kritisieren kann. Dazu komme ich gleich noch. Platz 5 bis 8 spielen dann nach der Saison die Playoffs um die Europa League. Aber das ist in dieser Saison nicht Platz 5 bis 8, sondern 6 bis 9. Wir haben den Pokalsieger aus Deventer. Deventer ist dadurch fix in der Europa League, da Deventer aber in der Liga auch siebter ist und einen guten Vorsprung hat auf den neunten Platz, nämlich von elf Punkten, spielen würden, die sich ziemlich sicher auch über die Liga für den internationalen Liga qualifizieren bzw. für eben jene Playoff-Runde. Das heißt, die nehmen wir heraus aus der Wertung, weil die sich mit dem Pokal qualifizieren. Deshalb haben wir dann Platz 6 bis 9, die sich dann nach der Saison zu viert, um das letzte Ticket für die Conference League qualifizieren. Und da haben wir auf dem neuen Zitad aktuell mit 36 Punkten. Sparta auf 10.35, Honiggen 35 Punkte auf 11, auf 12 ist Almelo, die haben auch 35 Punkte. Neumärchen 33, Predator der Aufsteiger auf 14 mit 32 und eben Zwolle auf 15 mit 31 Punkten. Nur 5 Punkte bei noch 4 Spieltagen hinter 9. Das heißt, selbst Zwolle kennt noch die Top 9. Das heißt, wir haben einen sehr spannenden, sehr offenen Kampf. Und da muss ich noch ein Team rausheben, negativer Art. Das ist nämlich Aset Alkmaar. Die hatten in den letzten 7 Liga-Spiele gar nicht mehr gewonnen. Die waren ja in der Hinrunde eins der Top-Teams, standen schon zeitlich auch einige Witze höher. Und dann ist bei denen Sven Mainans ausgefallen, verletzt. Der kam jetzt erst vergangenen Spieltag wieder auf den Rasen, in den letzten 20 Minuten. Der hat davor wochenlang gefehlt. Und da hat allein Lags natürlich nicht, aber auch ein Großteil. Das ist ja der Spielmacher eigentlich von Aset. Das ist die Nummer 10 bei Aset. Ohne ihn hat man schon gesehen, dass offensive Strukturen und Ideen gefehlt haben. Die haben keine Chance mehr auf Platz 4. Wenn es ganz schlecht läuft, verlieren die selbst die Spiele in der Conference League Playoffs. Und die haben wir jetzt auch gegen die Winter-Pokalfinale verloren. Die haben die Saison, anstatt sie zu vergolden, quasi schon gegen die Wand gefahren, muss man es deutlich sagen.
Aber das ist ja eine wirklich erstaunliche Konstellation. Das hatte ich so gar nicht auf dem Schirm. Zwolle, die reine Rechnerisch noch nicht vor dem Abstieg gerettet sind. Die können doch auf den Relegationsplatz rutschen. Sie spielen aber gleichzeitig um die Playoffs für die Conference League. Also im Grunde ist es… Aber wie wird denn das aufgenommen in den Niederlanden? Weil natürlich wirkt das bizarr. Und man kann natürlich jetzt die immer gern genommene Diskussion führen. Aber wir wollen doch nicht von Zwolle europäisch vertreten werden. Aber irgendwie ist es doch auch mega geil, dass quasi bis zuletzt die ganze Liga um was spielt.
Ja, das stimmt. Aber da hat man quasi ähnliche Argumente und eine ähnliche Debatte, wie in Deutschland um den Regierungsplatz generell. Dass man sagt, ist es dann wirklich fair, wenn jetzt zum Beispiel so ein Zwolle, weil sie hinten raus drei gute Spieler haben, werden dann irgendwie neunter, gewinnen dann in… Weil sie auch mal zwei gute Spiele… Genau, Bündner Altma, die am Ende vielleicht 20 Punkte mehr haben. Und dafür geht Altma komplett leer aus. Die in der Saison übergreifend eigentlich das deutlich bessere Team waren. Ich meine, Altma hat jetzt diese Schwächephase, okay, aber in der Hinrunde waren die… waren die Top-Mannschaft. Und Zwolle dann für drei gute Spiele in der Saison Endsport und für eine gute… für gute paar Spiele in der… in den Play-off-Runden zu belohnen. Und Altma so zu bestrafen, es geht in die ähnliche Richtung zu fragen, ist es verdient, wenn eine Mannschaft auf Platz 16 die ganze Saison über kurzig gespielt hat und dann wegen einem 0-0 und einem 1-0 in der Relegation dann nochmal Bundesliga spielen darf. Das heißt, die eine Sache… und die andere Sache ist ja, ich find's auch super und einfach auch geil, wenn so ein kleines Team oder wie beiden Aufsteiger, ja, Kroningen und Kukedet, ja. Und vor allem Kroningen, die haben nur einen Punkt hinter neun. So, das heißt, die haben wirklich gute Chancen, das zu schaffen. Und dann ist aber die Frage, ich hab so ein bisschen Kulk charakter, wäre eine schöne Geschichte auch einfach. Aber wenn man dann auf der Liga sagt, es geht ja auch um die 5-Jahres-Wertung, es geht um den Kroffizienten. Und da muss die Eredivise in den nächsten Jahren sehr hoch kämpfen, weil die gute Saison von Ajax bald bestrichen wird aus der 5-Jahres-Wertung und dann auch so Länder wie Belgien zum Beispiel dann vor die Liganten wären. Und dann ist natürlich die Frage, wie gut performt denn dann so ein Kroningen international, auch in der Conference League? Und da hat man dann schon die Frage, ist das für die Liga gut? Insofern, also es ist auf jeden Fall eine Spannungsfaktor. Wir werden am letzten Spieltag, am 18. Mai, den Sonntag, werden wir sicherlich im Laufe der 90 Minuten träuflich verschiedene Positionen haben, wo auch mit Sicherheit in der 90. plus 5 irgendeinen schütteliger Elfmeter dazu führt, dass irgendetwas komisches passiert. Das würden wir auf jeden Fall haben, glaube ich.
Ja, ist schon faszinierend. Und gleichzeitig ist es ja auch eine Rechnung, die nicht zu lösen ist. Also die ungefähre Gleichung oder der Term, den du aufmachen kannst, ist, gewinnen wir mehr dadurch, dass die Liga bis zuletzt spannend ist und deswegen die nationalen, also vor allem nationalen, TV-Rechte damit an Wert gewinnen. Oder verlieren wir mehr dadurch, dass jetzt im Extremfall ein Zwolle in die Conference League kommt, da sofort ausscheidet, wir einen europäischen Koeffizientenplatz verlieren, dadurch weniger europäische Einnahmen haben und dadurch vielleicht zwei, drei Stars, in Anführungszeichen, die Liga wechseln, weil die Teams oben weniger Geld bekommen. Das ist nicht aufzulösen. Das ist natürlich eine interessante Diskussion, weil Zwolle kann es eigentlich völlig egal sein. Und ich glaube, ganz, ganz vielen Fans kann es völlig egal sein, wie viele europäische Plätze man eigentlich wirklich hat. Aber auf der anderen Seite ist es natürlich dann doch auch nicht komplett irrelevant. Also es ist schwierig, aber interessant.
Was es noch eine Sache zeigt, die aktuelle Konstellation, ist eigentlich auch der große Kram der finanziellen Möglichkeiten der Teams. Wenn man sich anguckt, die oberen vier haben 60 Punkte, Ajax 74, dann 67, dann 62. Und ab Platz 8 bis 15 sind das neun Punkte Unterschied. Und da sieht man auch einfach, wie eng beisammen die jeweiligen Gruppen sind. Also wie eng beisammen die Vereine sind, die gemäßiger Champions League sind. Und vor allem, wie eng zusammen die Vereine sind, die im Mittelfeld sind und die immer laufen und absteigen. Das ist jetzt keine neue Erkenntnis. Aber es verdeutlicht das eigentlich nochmals sehr schön und sehr deutlich im Prinzip.
Ja, wobei da dann natürlich eigentlich dann die Antwort auf die Frage läge, was will man priorisieren, eben, dass der nationale Wettbewerb ausgeglichen ist oder dass man europäisch weiter hohe Einnahmen hat. Weil wenn du das nicht möchtest, dass es diese Cluster-Bildung gibt und wenn du eben ein möglichst breites Cluster im Mittelfeld haben willst, dann ist es so, wie es jetzt ist, perfekt. Dann kann überspitzt gesagt jeder mal europäisch reinrutschen, jeder mal einmal europäisch irgendwie ein bisschen Geld verdienen und merchandise ein bisschen mehr und so weiter und so fort. Und dieser Block wird größer werden. Und das ist ja eigentlich eine Entwicklung, die wir in vielen Ligen gerade sehen, dass es einen sehr eng beieinander kondensierten Mittelfeld-Block gibt, weil die Spitze oben sich entfernt hat. Und wenn du aber sagst, nee, uns ist es wichtig, dass wir europäisch mithalten, dann wird sich die Spitze weiter entfernen. Dann wird das immer so bleiben, dass du halt zwischen Champions League und nicht Champions League 15 Punkte hast. Oder Europa League ist es ja sogar in dem Fall. Ja, interessant. Aber siehst du, deswegen machen wir diese Ligaturen, weil das hatte ich gar nicht mitbekommen. Und jetzt weiß ich, dass ich Roningen, Breda und Zwolle, das sind jetzt meine Teams. Vorher waren es die Go Ahead Eagles, aber die hatten jetzt ihren Erfolg. Wir alle haben die grünen Bademäntel im Pokalfinale gesehen. Fantastisch, wirklich einfach, fantastisch. Und ich bin auch sehr froh, dass du mich rechtzeitig draufgebracht hast, dass ich die verfolgt habe. So, und jetzt sind es Roningen, Breda und Zwolle. Go for it! Ich will euch unbedingt in der Conference League sehen. Dann gegen, wer wird da eigentlich in Deutschland reinkommen? Tja, Gladbach. Wenn sie Glück haben, Dortmund. Naja, schauen wir mal. Das wird lustig. So, und dann blicken wir nochmal auf Spanien. Und da wird es ja keine Playoff-Regelungen geben, die mir erklärt wird. Aber was ist denn da wichtig zu wissen, Fabian?
Nee, Playoff gibt es keine. Aber es kann sogar sein, dass bis zu neun Teams nächstes Jahr aus Spanien international spielen. Also wahrscheinlich werden die ersten fünf in die Champions League kommen. Vier sind ja fix. Der fünfte wird es wahrscheinlich werden über den UEFA-Koeffizienten. Und Barcelona, Real Madrid ist ja klar. Atletico Madrid wird wie immer gefühlt wie immer wahrscheinlich dritter werden. Und im Moment sieht es sehr gut aus für Atletico Bilbao, für einen baskischen Club, der eine sehr starke Saison spielt, auf Tabellenposition 4 im Moment steht. Rang 5 wird wahrscheinlich Villarreal oder Betis unter sich ausmachen. Das wird wahrscheinlich noch sehr offen sein. Und dann haben wir meine Freunde von Celta Vigo. Die hatten wir ganz am Anfang der Ligatour schon besprochen. Die sind zwischenzeitlich mal fast runter bis in die Abstiegsränge gerutscht und haben sich jetzt wieder nach oben gekämpft, sind im Moment siebter. Ich bin sehr zuversichtlich, weil die haben gerade echt einen guten Lauf, dass die das europäisch auch schaffen werden. Ja und dann kämpfen wahrscheinlich noch Teams wie Osasuna, Mallorca und Real Sociedad San Sebastian noch um den letzten europäischen Platz. Aber ich gehe mal davon aus, Champions League, wie gesagt, Atletico Madrid, Atleti Club de Bilbao und Villarreal oder Betis. Und dann eben Celta Vigovic packen und dann Osasuna, Mallorca, San Sebastian. Je nachdem, was da noch so ansteht, man darf ja nicht vergessen, Atleti Bilbao steht im Halbfinale der Europa League, Betis im Halbfinale der Conference League. Wenn die ihre Titel gewinnen, dann gibt es dann eben doch den 9. Platz dazu. Und so kann noch einiges verschoben werden, sagen wir mal so.
Aber wenn es den 9. Platz dazu gäbe, dann wären ja rein theoretisch, dann ging es ja noch bis Radio. Die sind drei Punkte hinter dem 9. Platz. Dann mache ich jetzt mal den Cut, weil ich großzügig bin. Fünf Punkte Abstand werden das sonst. Aber die Geschichte schlechthin wäre es ja eigentlich, wenn es Valencia irgendwie noch schafft, nach dieser Saison zu schaffen.
Die könnten es tatsächlich noch packen. Und die haben eigentlich einen ganz guten Lauf inzwischen seit dem Trainerwechsel. Also es sind ja noch fünf Spiele. Das sind immerhin noch 15 Punkte. Also es ist jetzt nicht völlig ausgeschlossen. Und ob es verdient ist, oder ob es wieder der andere steht, wird auch vom ganz anderen Stern. Ich hoffe mal ganz ehrlich aus persönlicher Fäntum, dass San Sebastian es noch schafft. Das Team tut mir dieses Jahr richtig leid. Die haben die Doppelbelastung überhaupt nicht in den Griff bekommen. Die mussten ja ziemlich viele Spieler abgeben am Anfang der Saison. Sie hatten dann extrem viele Verletzte und krebsen sich so ein bisschen durch die Saison. Der Trainer, Immanuel Aguasil, hat ja angekündigt, dass er am Ende der Saison aufhört. Der hat nach sechs Jahren auch die Schnauze voll sozusagen. Also bzw. der wird dann eben aufhören. Sie haben extrem viel geleistet in den letzten Jahren und zahlen jetzt im Moment so ein bisschen das Bußgeld dafür. Ich hoffe, dass sie es in den letzten Spielen dann noch unter die Top 9 oder Top 8 schaffen.
Und wie wird das verfolgt in Spanien? Ich meine, klar, auf einmal ist es so, dass alle mit den entsprechenden Fähnchen die Europapokalspiele von anderen verfolgen, weil sie hoffen, dass die jetzt alle die Titel holen, damit es dann wirklich neun Europapokal-Teilnehmer der Liga wären. Aber eigentlich ist ja mit dem UEFA-Koeffizienten jetzt das eingetreten, was man erwartet hatte damals, als es eingeführt wurde, als es quasi hieß, die beiden besten Ligen bekommen noch mal zwei zusätzliche Plätze. Und dann haben alle gesagt, ah ja, der geht dann an die Premier League und der geht an La Liga. Dann war es im ersten Jahr nicht so. Da hat ja unter anderem Deutschland davon profitiert. Ist das jetzt quasi die Herstellung der natürlichen Ordnung? Wie wird denn das in Spanien begleitet?
Ja, also die Spanier sind schon sehr selbstbewusst. Und sie sehen sich schon europäisch ganz weit vorne. Und von daher glaube ich, sind sie da schon so stolz, dass sie sagen, ja, den haben wir uns schon auch verdient. Ist ja auch im Endeffekt so. Man muss ja auch wirklich sagen, in den letzten Jahren, die Spanier sind eigentlich immer, im Halbfinale war immer ein Spanier dabei mindestens. Und in der Champions League mit Real Madrid haben wir ja genug erlebt, sag ich mal, in den letzten Jahren, wie oft sie es gewonnen haben. Also die sind schon auf europäischer Ebene wirklich sehr hoch anzusiedeln. Es gibt da natürlich schon Gefälle. Jetzt auch in der Conference League oder Europa League haben es nicht alle Teams gut gemacht, wie auch San Sebastian zum Beispiel. Da ist es dann nicht ganz so einfach. Aber so diese ersten vier, fünf, sechs Teams vielleicht in Spanien, die sind schon normalerweise in Europa immer sehr gut dabei.
Also wir werden es genau verfolgen. Ich danke euch beiden. Und wenn alles geklappt hat, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, dann hören wir jetzt noch einen Aufsager von Christian zur Serie A. Es tut uns sehr leid, dass wir es nicht anders hinbekommen haben. Aber bitte, Christian, take it away, wie es im Sportradio 360 immer heißt. Wie ist die Lage in der Serie A?
Was das Rennen um die Europapokalplätze betrifft, Max, können wir es in Italien fast um einen Rennen um die Champions League-Plätze ausweiten. Denn– Achtung– bis zur achtplatzierten Fiorentina haben alle noch wirklich realistische Chancen, sich für die Champions League zu qualifizieren. Zwischen Juve auf Platz 4 und der Fiorentina auf 8 liegen nur drei Punkte. Und das Schöne ist, dass all die Mannschaften, die damit drin sind– also Atalanta, Juve, Bologna, Roma, Lazio und die Fiorentina– an den letzten vier Spieltagen noch mehrfach gegeneinander spielen. Also jeder dieser Teams hat noch mindestens ein direktes Duell. Mehrere Mannschaften, zum Beispiel Juve sogar zwei, die haben jetzt zunächst Bologna, dann kriegen sie noch Lazio. Also alles direkte Duelle. Dementsprechend haben sie alle Mannschaften auch eigentlich noch selbst in der Hand. Und ja, schauen wir uns mal kurz uns an, Mannschaft für Mannschaft, wie da die Chancen stehen. Beginnen wir mit Atalanta. Die sind auf 3, die haben ein kleines Polster auf Rang 5, nämlich 4 Punkte. Also da deutet jetzt einiges drauf hin, dass Atalanta diesen dritten Platz sozusagen holen wird. Warum? Weil sie zuletzt wichtige, Stichwort direkte Duelle für sich entschieden haben. Haben zuletzt Milan geschlagen, haben zu Lotz Bologna geschlagen, vor einigen Wochen auch Juve geschlagen. Also, obwohl es bei Atalanta in den vergangenen Wochen ja auch nicht immer rund lief, aber gerade in diesen direkten Duellen waren sie da. Und dementsprechend deutet jetzt vieles darauf hin, dass Gasperini und seine Elf auf ein paar Champions-League-Plätze einlaufen werden. Auf 4 ist Juve. Da müsste man eigentlich irgendwann dann auch mal, Max, noch eine eigene Sendung machen, denn da wir jetzt so eine lange Pause hatten, mittlerweile ist Thiago Motta ja gar nicht mehr Trainer bei Juve, sondern das Kapitel ist ja bereits Geschichte. Igor Tudor hat Juve übernommen und hat es in den ersten fünf Spielen sehr ordentlich bis gut gemacht. Juve hat drei dieser fünf Spiele gewonnen. Dazu gab es ein Unentschieden gegen die Roma, so ein bisschen aus der Reihe tanzt die Niederlage in Parma. Aber wie gesagt, Juve hat sich stabilisiert, konnte, äh, konnte es schon, sorry, Tudor hat aufgrund seiner langjährigen Juve-Vergangenheit das irgendwie geschafft, sozusagen da ein bisschen wieder eine positive Stimmung reinzubekommen. Also sowohl die Spieler als auch das Umfeld nimmt ihm diese lange Juve-Geschichte ab, hat relativ simple Sachen gemacht, hat jetzt immer dasselbe System spielen lassen, 3-4-2-1, auch die meisten Positionen sehr verlässlich besetzt, also anders als Thiago Motta, der wahnsinnig viel rotiert hat. Also Tudor scheint da wie gesagt einen ganz guten Schlüssel jetzt gefunden zu haben, um Juve da eben in diesen letzten Spielen in die Champions League zu bringen, was hier das große Ziel sozusagen ist. Wie gesagt, die Besonderheit, sie haben jetzt noch Bologna und Lazio, also hintereinander zwei direkte Konkurrenten. Und Kinnenhildis ist am vergangenen Wochenende wegen einer Tätigkeit mit Rot vom Platz geflogen. Ich gehe mal stark davon aus, dass der mehrere Spiele sperren bekommen wird. Also der wird Juve jetzt definitiv fehlen, aber Juve ist eigentlich in diesen engen Rennen schon in einer ganz guten Position. Gehen wir auf Rang 5, da liegt Bologna. Für mich ja eigentlich die Mannschaft fast des Jahres, wieder noch Serie A. Also was Vincenzo Italiano, die Arbeit fortgeführt hat von Thiago Motta, sensationell. Dazu kommt bei Bologna, dass sie auch noch im Coppa Italia-Finale sind gegen Milan. Jetzt in zwei Wochen, also auch da noch eine Aussicht auf einen großen Titel, der Bologna schon lange fehlt. Große Arbeit, die Bologna leistet, wie gesagt, einfach mitten in dem Rennen drin zu sein. Sie haben Juve noch, das direkte Duell zu Hause. Also auch Bologna hat alle Möglichkeiten, diesen vierten Platz sich selbst zu ergattern. Kleine negative Rande und Lütze, Denen Deuje, der Schweizer Nationalspieler, der hat sich jetzt vor wenigen Tagen verletzt, droht wohl auch, mehrere Wochen auszufallen. Warum erwähne ich ihn? Weil er wirklich einer der formstärksten, einer sehr formstarken Bologna-Mannschaft zuletzt war, also das wird jetzt Bologna treffen. Aber die große Qualität von Bologna liegt eigentlich schon die ganze Saison darin, dass sie eben vielfältig aufgestellt sind. Orsolini zuletzt wieder, ganz wichtige Tore, mehrere wichtige, schöne Tore, auch das späte Sieg der Nachspielzeit gegen Inter erst vor kurzem. Also Italiano hat mehrere Optionen und ich würde sagen, da ist auch eine gewisse Leichtigkeit bei Bologna dabei, denn anders als Juve oder eben andere große Namen, wenn die schon den großen Druck haben, in die Champions League fast kommen zu müssen, ist das eigentlich bei Bologna kein Muss, sondern ein schönen Traum, den sie weiter verfolgen. Die ganze Stadt steht dahinter, das ganze Umfeld. Vor kurzem waren mal beim Training 2000 Fans, 2000 unter der Woche und das zeigt eben, dass da eine große positive Stimmung da ist. Dazu noch das Coppa Italia-Finale, also mit Bologna ist zu rechnen. Dahinter haben wir die Roma. Die Roma, einfach nur ein Wort, sensationell, was Claudio Ranieri mit der Roma gemacht hat. Noch mal zur Erinnerung, als er die übernommen hat, hatte die Roma 2 Punkte Vorsprung auf den Abstiegsplatz, auf den ersten. So, und jetzt sind 4 Spieltage vor Schluss, liegen nur noch 2 Punkte hinter den Champions League-Rängen. Seit 19 Spielen jetzt mittlerweile ungeschlagen. Eben am vergangenen Sonntag der Sieg in San Siro gegen Inter. Das nächste Statement, was Ranieri gemacht hat, einfach großartig. Die Roma ist schwer zu knacken. Die Roma funktioniert auch ohne Di Balla, der mittlerweile schon seit einigen Wochen verletzungsbedingt fehlt. Zuletzt waren es wieder Sole, der das entscheidende Tor gegen Inter gemacht hat, oder Schomo Rodolf, oder auch Cristante zum Beispiel, der ein großes Spiel gerade in San Siro gegen das Inter Mittelfeld geliefert hat. Spieler, die zum Beispiel vor einigen Monaten überhaupt keine Rolle gespielt haben und die es eben Ranieri auch geschafft hat, wieder auf Kurs zu bringen. Also alleine, dass die Roma ja noch die reelle Chance auf die Champions League hat, ist eigentlich ein kleines fußballerisches Wunder. Die Roma hatten wahrscheinlich das schwerste Restprogramm von allen, aber eben wie gesagt, allein durch den Dreier jetzt gegen Inter haben sie auch gezeigt, dass sie auch in den direkten Duellen da noch einiges bewegen können. Und deswegen einfach, ja, ich sage mal, der positive Schwung, der ist definitiv auf Seiten der Roma. Dahinter Lazio, Punkt gleich mit der Roma, auch nur zwei Punkte hinter der vierplatzierten Juve. Ja, ist zuletzt vielleicht ein bisschen ins Stocken geraten. Lazio war ja vor einigen Wochen noch durchaus in der Pole-Position, was diesen, sage ich mal, vierten Rang betrifft. Zuletzt ja auch in der Europa League ausgeschieden, aber eben auch weiterhin voll im Rennen. Hat eben noch das Direkturale gegen Juve, wo sie rein theoretisch eben mit einem Sieg an Juve vorbeiziehen können. Haben Tati Castellanos wieder zurück. Der Neuner, der Mittelstürmer, der hat ihnen wochenlang gefehlt. Und da hat man auch gesehen, dass der offensive Output darunter gelitten hat, nicht nur aufgrund der Tore des Argentiniers, sondern auch aufgrund seines großen Einflusses auf das Laziospiels, macht viele Bälle fest, ist einfach ein Neuner, der für diese Mannschaft sehr wichtig ist. Pedro am vergangenen Wochenende wieder mit einem Doppelpack, also auch die Erfahrung von Pedro tut der Lazio gut. Und ich würde auch sagen, sie haben auch so ein bisschen Außenseiter. Es sind in der Außenseiterrolle, also ich glaube nicht, dass von Lazio jetzt unbedingt verlangt wird, dass sie in die Champions League müssen. Dementsprechend können sie das vielleicht auch ein bisschen befreiter angehen. Ja, und dann haben wir noch die Fiorentina auf Rang 8, die liegt drei Punkte hinter dem vierten Platz, hat zuletzt auch wieder aufsteigende Formen bewiesen, hat Robin Goossens, das muss man da hervorheben, hat zuletzt einige wichtige Tore geschossen, eben auf der linken Außenbahn. Ken hat jetzt ein, zwei Spiele gefehlt aus persönlichen Gründen, der kommt hoffentlich wieder zurück, das ist logisch ganz wichtig für die Fiorentina, die auch noch im Conference League-Halbfinale ist, das dürfen wir auch nicht vergessen. Also die haben wirklich auch noch eine Zusatzbelastung mit mindestens zwei Spielen mehr. Das macht es jetzt sicherlich nicht einfach im Kampf um Platz 4. Und was bei der Fiorentina sicherlich jetzt negativ ins Gewicht schlagen könnte, ist, dass Dodor, der rechte Schienenspieler, der wie groß und extrem wichtig für die Mannschaft ist, erstmal ausfällt, weil er am Blinddarm operiert wurde. Aber trotzdem, auch bei der Fiorentina, sie sind im Rennen, sie sind mittendrin und auch die Fiorentina hat noch ein direktes Duell. Also auch da ist alles noch möglich. Und der letzte Satz vielleicht noch, denn auf 9 liegt Milan, also eigentlich eine dieser Mannschaften, die man auf jeden Fall unter den Top 4 hatten, die haben wirklich 8 Punkte Rückstand auf Platz 4. Also das Ding ist eigentlich durch die Champions League. Bei Milan liegen jetzt die großen Hoffnungen auf das Coppa Italia-Finale. Sie haben ja Inter rausgeworfen im Halbfinale und würden da mit einem Sieg sich sozusagen als Coppa Italia-Sieger sich direkt für die Europa League qualifizieren. Das ist jetzt sicherlich das große Ziel von Milan, um diese Saison, die dann zwar am Ende mit zwei Titeln enden könnte, denn die Supercoppa haben es ja schon gewonnen, dann trotzdem eine sehr, sehr schwierige Saison zu beenden. Denn ein Kader von Milan, also mit diesen Einzelspielern als neunter in der Liga nach 34 Spieltagen, das zeigt schon, wie viel schief bei Milan in dieser Saison in der Liga gelaufen ist.
Danke, Christian, für deine Infos. Und ich danke natürlich auch Daniel und Fabian, dass ihr hier allen technischen Widrigkeiten getrotzt habt. Man muss auch sagen, derjenige, der den Stromausfall hatte gestern, wo überhaupt nicht klar, wie lange das gehen würde, der war mit weitem Abstand am Stabiesten hier mit dabei. Fabian, ich ziehe meinen Hut, nicht schlecht.
Man muss den Spanien eins lassen, Internet, wenn es Strom gibt, dann ist das Internet wirklich top. Dann ist es wirklich top und auch sehr, sehr günstig. Also von daher freut mich, dass alles geklappt hat.
Aber wirklich, was für ein Satz auch einfach, wenn es Strom gibt, dann ist das Internet wirklich super. Ganz kurz, ich muss die Frage einmal kurz stellen, wie war denn das gestern mit dem Stromausfall? Das ist ja auf eine Art und Weise bezahlbar, weil wie hat zum Beispiel dann das Weitergeben von Nachrichten funktioniert? Weil ja auch Radiosender etc. keinen Strom hatten.
Die Radiosender waren die ersten, die wieder gesendet haben und plötzlich waren sämtliche Transistorenradios, also diese alten Radios, wo man noch die Frequenz einstellt, ausverkauft. Hast du so eins? Nein, ja natürlich nicht. Natürlich nicht. Ich bin ins Auto gegangen und habe im Auto ein Radio gehört. Im Auto gibt es das natürlich. Da gibt es ja noch die Antenne um. Also habe ich im Auto ein bisschen Radio gehört. Aber es war tatsächlich so, wir sind dann runtergekommen. Alle Supermärkte, alles hat zugemacht natürlich. Die Einzigen, die noch auf haben, waren so kleine Chinesen. Die haben halt alles Mögliche. Und die haben aufgelassen und dann sind wir zu zwei, drei verschiedenen hin und wollten so ein kleines Radio haben und alles ausverkauft natürlich. Die Spanier haben sofort angefangen mit Hamsterkäufen. Also Klopapier, Wasser, alles wurde sofort wieder für die nächsten fünf Jahre gekauft und so weiter. Und es war echt bizarr.
Aber ohne Kartenzahlung ja auch. Du musst ja dann Bargeld zahlen. Ja eben, wer hat denn Bargeld zu Hause? Oh Gott, ich wäre völlig… im Falle eines Ernstfalls bin ich komplett aufgeschmissen.
Ihr müsst die EU folgen bzw. es gibt diesen Survival-Kit oder was auch immer. Ich glaube, man sollte ihn sich tatsächlich…
Es gibt es für Deutschland auch, ja.
Es macht Sinn. Also ich bin mal gespannt, was rauskommt. Wir wissen ja nach wie vor nicht, was der Grund war. Es war plötzlich um 12.30 Uhr 60% des Stroms weg und das hat dazu geführt, dass das gesamte Netz kollabiert ist. Es gibt die Theorie, dass in Frankreich bzw. dass Spanien in Frankreich dann vom europäischen Netz abgekoppelt worden ist. Warum weiß man nicht. Es gibt die Theorie, dass zu viel Photovoltaik produziert worden ist bzw. zu viele erneuerbare Egenen und dass das System dadurch kollapsiert worden ist. Es gibt natürlich auch die Theorie der Cyber-Attacke. Wir wissen es noch nicht, aber es war schon bizarr, wenn man überlegt, einige Haushalte haben erst heute Morgen wieder Strom bekommen. Das sind dann mehr als 12 Stunden ohne Strom. Bei uns waren es nur vier. Wir hatten echt viel Glück. Und das ist schon heftig eigentlich. Ja, interessant, was wir so in den letzten Jahren hier alles erleben. Wir haben mit Covid angefangen und dann die Wasserfluten und jetzt Stromausfall.
Also, du nimmst es auch wirklich mit. Ich meine, wir haben hier eine Ligatur aufgenommen während Corona in der einen Stunde, in der Kinder und Familie raus durften. Du hast gesagt, nee, lasst uns trotzdem eine Ligatur aufnehmen, wo ich bis heute ein schlechtes Gewissen habe. Dann eben diese Niederschläge. Jetzt das. Also es ist absolut bizarr. Und ich kann euch nur empfehlen, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, schaut euch mal das an. Es gibt von der Bundesregierung, was man quasi haben soll, unter anderem Konservendosen für drei Monate. Ich glaube, 100 Liter Wasser soll man einfach immer da haben. Viel Spaß mit, das in eurer völlig überteuerten Mietwohnung in einer Großstadt irgendwo in dem anderthalb Zimmer noch unterzubringen. Also absolut. Gut, und ich meine, dass für mich sowieso sämtliche Perspektive auch beruflich futsch ist, sollte es mal irgendwie keinen Strom geben. Das ist ja auch völlig klar. Dann kommt ja nicht mal mehr euer Support bei uns an, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer. Gott um Gottes Willen, bald muss ich hier Barspenden einsammeln. Also schön, dass es dennoch geklappt hat, Fabian. Und ich bin gespannt, was quasi dann im nächsten Jahr passiert. Es ist ja immer so jährlich ein großes Ding. Aber trotzdem, bei dir hat es geklappt. Danke dir und ich danke natürlich auch Daniel Zander. Keine Ahnung, warum du auch mehrmals wegfasst. Ich weiß auch gar nicht, ob es überhaupt ein Video gegeben haben wird zu dieser Sendung hier. Aber ich danke dir, dass auch du allem getrotzt hast und mir das vor allem mit den Playoffs erklären konntest. Wahnsinn, dass ich das nicht wusste. Und ich schimpfe mich Sportjournalist. Wahnsinn.
Danke dir.
Gerne, gerne.
Gerne wieder.
Und dann danke ich natürlich auch in Abwesenheit Christian Bernhard und Uli Hebel. Und ich danke euch, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörern, entschuldigt das Ganze hin und her. Ich hoffe, es war für euch dennoch ein Hörgenuss unter mitmachen.rasenfunk.de. Da könnte uns gerne Feedback zu dieser Sendung geben. Und in der Folge möchte ich mich bedanken bei Jule Jakob, Tobias Gebhardt, mit dem Jürgen bei Simon Gofegantse-Johann und bei Eresi von der Alm. Esresi von der Alm, sie alle sind Rasenfunk-Supporter. Erinnern auf rasenfunk.de, erfahrt ihr, wie man uns unterstützen kann. Noch nicht in Bar, aber alles andere geht. Und vielleicht muss ich das mit Frank demnächst mal besprechen. Und ansonsten wünsche ich euch eine gute Zeit. Hört dem Rasenfunk auch den anderen Feeds. Es wird hier heute noch eine weitere Ligatur zur 2. Liga geben. Es wird ein Tribüngespräch geben. Schwerpunkt zu Leverkusen bei den Männern. Und die Spieltags-Sendungen zur Frauen-Bundesliga und zur Männer-Bundesliga, die sind ja schon erschienen. Also es gibt viel, viel, viel zu hören. Und vielleicht auch viele Gründe, den Rasenfunk zu unterstützen. Ganz herzlichen Dank an alle, die das schon getan haben. Bleibt gesund und macht keine Hamster-Korte weg. Bis bald. Ciao. Der Rasenfunk lebt von euren Beiträgen. Vielen Dank.